breaking news so great inut time okay
are we ready for breaking news um we
have news in from CNN they are reporting
from CNN Sports from CNN Sports that Doc
Rivers has accepted the Milwaukee Bucks
head coaching position as you may
remember earlier today Adrien Griffin
relieved of Duties uh they were second
or third best record in the NBA and CNN
Sports is now reporting that Doc Rivers
will be the next coach of the Milwaukee
bucks the athletic had some reports
earlier that during the inseason
tournament Doc Rivers was being used to
give advice to Adrien Griffin to try and
help out the firste head coach and now
about a month later Doc Rivers is the
head coach of the Milwaukee Bucks Shaq
you said earlier in pregame that there's
something else going on here Beyond how
we got here your thoughts of Doc Rivers
as the coach well he does have
Championship experience he does have
experience with dealing with a large
name individual Superstars Dame Lillard
and Giannis and he does have experience
with being a defensive mind of Coach but
again as a player you have to want to
play defense you have to want to have
timely stops and again when you're the
one two punch on the team you rely on
the coach in my opinion a little bit not
a lot like you have to say hey this is
what we need to do hey you need to get
in line boom boom bam but uh you know a
big name coach I'm I'm happy for Doc and
he gets a chance to you know get another
one because you know for so long he's
just been you know surviving off that
one Championship so I would like to see
him get another one I have heard a lot
of comparisons today towards David blat
David blat in that 2016 season started
off 30 and 11 he was let go teron Lou
came in they won the championship but
Lou was an assistant on that roster Doc
Rivers has not been on this coaching
staff but he was a
consultant yeah he was a consultant so
what does that mean as someone who's
never been in that locker room he knows
what's going on if you're Consulting a
guy helping him out obious the guys you
know saying he helped what should I do
yeah yeah oh helped him out got
it we don't know now Joe PR uh uh so
with with Doc Rivers trying to fix this
defense you guys were actually talking
the back about in the NBA right now so
many things are similar schemes is it
easier in today's NBA to come in in the
middle of the Season like this what kind
of hurdles do you think doc has ahead of
him yeah I think it's easier because
everything looks the same offensively
defensively that's why players get
traded it's almost Plug and Play you
don't have to like when we were coming
up it was like okay these are our top
five plays give a assistant coach so you
can study these plays it's different now
now it's just plug and play Go side to
side get down here with a pick and roll
you got a good one go to a great one
it's three-pointer get as many threes as
possible so you can do that anywhere
it's no different than almost open gym
in some ways you can play with guys who
know how to play you can just plug and
play so for them I think it'll be easier
and if Doc's been watching their team
and Consulting some way shape or form he
watches the lead League anyway I'm sure
he'll fit right in I think uh also it's
not been their offense and I don't think
it'll ever be their offense when you
have Giannis on your team and you have
Dame Lillard on your team it was their
defense I mean that Milwaukee Bucks team
is 22nd at one point defensively in the
league and that just can't happen if you
have aspirations to win a championship
and so with that being said I don't
think there's ever been a question about
Doc and defense I think that there were
questions of Doc offensively but not
questions about Doc's defensive
philosophy and we're trying to cover up
holes just lost Drew holiday which is
one of the best perimeter defenders in
the league yeah but if you're looking at
these players right here these are
effort players like you don't have you
got to get back like you just show four
Hol two open guys and get back you got
to turn around don't you think that's
Buy in too like you have guys that
aren't getting back defensively you want
to do it I think you you have to know
and real that's buying with a coach as
well well but but hold on how what do we
expect like yeah we lost Drew holiday
but you you figured you didn't really
lose him you traded him to get Dame
Lillard you were going to lose defense
you said okay we're giving up this
defense to be more of a high-powered
offense that's what you're getting I
just looked up until tonight Denver and
the defending champs and Milwaukee Bucks
had the same record and they fired their
coach and Denver's like we're just truck
along we're doing what we're doing so
what they expect to happen defensively
if you're giving up Dame for Drew but
don't you think that optically the
record didn't tell the story because
looking at Milwaukee you were like
something's not right but even then
that's not you're right and agree with
you but that's not fast to pull the
trigger they still have the second best
record yeah if they like I'm in
agreement with you but I think you have
players like Giannis I mean again I'll
go back to what Chris Hayne said if you
have players that aren't buying into
what the coach is saying and then you
also have an organization that hired
this coach not to win a
championship to me that was that was
number one where you said okay well then
our aspirations changed when we got Dame
Lillard there have been stories that
have raised questions throughout the
basketball community this entire season
before the final preseason game he got
into a verbal altercation with assistant
Terry stots two days later Terry STS
resigned later on the Year Bobby poris
called like a team only meeting said we
don't believe in the scheme then in
January they came and they said we don't
think this defense they've constantly
been questioning the scheme throughout
the year I agree with you they have the
same record as the Denver Nuggets as
Shaq in the pregame something is going
on not getting out right and I've always
said if you're a great player you don't
respect your
coach so at least doc could get a little
bit more respect has a championship been
around League you know knows how to deal
with those type of players listen he's a
young guy yeah who was NBA player like
if you're Giannis would you listen to
him if you're Dame Lillard would you
listen to him but let me ask this
question as an organization youve just
mentioned all those things right but
then you hire somebody that's a
consultant and then comes in and takes
the job don't you think that that's a
little from an organization with consult
with a great
resum say it again a consultant with a
great resume in agreement but was this
consultant to take the job initially
anyway because have they really faltered
that much since the end season
tournament one other note Underdog just
whispered in my ear up until now the
Bucks have had the easiest strength of
schedule going forward they have the
toughest strength of schedule so the
series The Season really does start now
just to wrap you guys have been on teams
in which the coach has been let go what
is when a new coach comes in does it
really change the energy does it feel
like a fresh start for everybody at
first like the first couple days you
remember when Harden went to Philly last
year or the year before and the first
few games were like oh they're the new
kobian Shaq we didn't say it but we
heard that right the honeymoon period is
going to end in a week or two and then
reality sets in so that part of it like
you you wanted them to adjust with Dame
coming now you got to adjust the Dame
and Doc so is that that honeymoon we
kind of have two weeks until the
All-Star break you kind of do these two
weeks then get like a week off to maybe
figure some out and planning is that the
mindset you think they're doing I think
that's the mindset there is a fresh
beginning and then also it puts puts the
onus on the players we've done
everything that you have wanted to do
you got the trade you got Dame Lillard
okay you have the pieces to possibly win
a championship even though I still think
that they're going to make one more move
and then now we've changed the coach so
I think that that changes the energy of
like okay I got to get back in
transition defense I got to buy into the
scheme because this is what the players
have wanted but I do think and this how
I thought personally I do think resumes
are important because again if you never
been where I'm trying to go do I believe
you think you need more people and you
yourself have been there yeah but when
Phil Jackson came when he said something
I was like and then when I was playing
with Stan Van guny hell of a coach but
when he you know got got replaced with
Pat Riley we all know who Pat Raleigh is
like I watch Pat Raley growing up so
whenever he says something not only will
I pay attention but all all the guys
were pay what was it like playing for
doc I I mean it wasn't my time so but
you saw the way he commanded a locker
room and talk to the team I mean he he
treated him like men he had great plays
you know he had great schemes and you
know the guys respecting them but Rondo
uh kg and Paul they really took control
of that lock we're about to watch the
Clippers possibly beat the Lakers for a
long left go get his wolitzer there was
only one Kobe and sha by the way don't
get that Twisted oh good Clippers W
starting